[Applaudissements]
ça représente parfaitement Guillaume en
fait il était un félin il patiente
silencieusement
sauter dans les bras tout à l'heure
[Applaudissements]
est-ce qu'il ferait
c'est ce qu'on attend j'entends un smack
on verra ce matin
[Applaudissements]
ça me rappelle des souvenirs
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
une baraque à frites il va encore sortir
des horreurs ma maman s'appelle
Louisette oui c'est joli c'est mignon
par contre non non non non non non non
non non
Cyril on arrête parce que moi je n'en
peux plus
Jean-Marc la famille
comment votre maman
je sens le truc arriver là ça me fait
peur je vais partir Cyril
c'est très joli oui ça va oui alors là
mais moi je ne sais même pas pourquoi je
suis là
on m'a dit viens il y a 30 minutes on
m'a dit viens là bas
si vous voulez ouais d'accord ok avec
plaisir
[Rires]
merci à tous en tout cas de l'avoir
passé des extraits cette année chez
Jordan d'avoir parlé merci beaucoup à
Kelly parce que tu es toujours très
gentil avec moi c'est pas le cas tous
les chroniqueurs mais franchement
j'ai le Verdun
[Applaudissements]
il faut que vous alliez boire un verre à
la buvette avec vos amis ça vous fera du
bien
c'est la dernière
[Rires]
de faire du mal à une personne
gentil
je t'aime beaucoup
oui mais c'est pas la même jeunesse
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pour toi
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
par SMS de ta mère
comment ça faire des SMAC
[Rires]
on oublie ce que je viens de dire
chérie
en fait en télévision faut jamais
revenir exactement bravo en télévision
[Rires]
sinon
c'est trop loin
[Applaudissements]